it's in your choosing that your
character is formed
which gives you the right kind of
direction in your life
choice and deliberation
give me an example of a unwilling act
that we do
well like when i was younger and you had
to clean up your mom made you clean up
your room and you didn't want to clean
up your room
but you did it because you're kind of
forced to just by the way
a perfect example because
the hard choices typically involve some
element
of duress so when you're a child
your parents do that for you right they
in the end there really isn't an option
when you're not of age
right because you're a long way from
being mature enough to
take off and leave them and might not be
able to make it stick
if he did what is the process by which
choices are produced
is that what we call deliberation it is
explain that
so deliberation instead of debating
about what the ends are
of our actions deliberation is about
selecting the best means
by which we attain those ends
so liberation's not about ends where do
ends come from
our nature our nature
our nature cultivated it says wish
so ends our wish for and i i guess
depending on your nature you're going to
wish for
better or worse ends because of what
they desire
it's a good natural desire better ends
than a bad nature
it's a this demand of
leaving a life of character an ethical
life
it's in your choosing that your
character is formed which gives you
the right kind of direction in your life
we're about to see when we separate
each act into its component parts
it's always made up of two things what
you want
and an estimation of the circumstances
and what you want is is achieved the
right thing
by practice and and thought
about what the right way to live is and
what the right kind of person is and
about what the ultimate ends are
and remember you're making these
deliberations
if they're the kind that are meaningful
in the shaping of your character
you're making them under pressure it
means they're stakes
it means that you might get hurt or fail
to get some large benefit
it means that you're likely to be tired
you have to decide right now and you can
never be sure
because you can never be sure of the
future you can never be sure of the
consequences what you do
you have to make a guess
and you get better at that by trying it
but the guessing part itself
because what matters the most what is
the thing when you make a choice that
matters the most
about whether it tends to build virtue
in you or not what is that thing
intention intention
what do you want when you get older
you'll figure this out
the what you want part when you make a
choice
will be more important to how you
remember the choice
and how you regard yourself than what
specifically you chose to do
and what the result was you ever crashed
the car
any of the girls ever crashed a car
yeah i see don't represent that guys it
doesn't seem fair but it does seem true
doesn't it
i crashed him all the time when i was a
kid why because
i didn't you know i never crashed one
bad but you know
my dad was not a rich man i'd break his
cars
and why i was young and stupid
inexperienced you see so just remember
even in this formative time in your life
what you seek is is the thing
that has to be got right
and if you get used to that you'll get
better and better at the job of seeking
it
that's what changes your character
that's what shapes it informs it
makes you what you are
i'm larry iron president of hillsdale
college you will find if you look at our
online courses that they cover the whole
range of human learning
all the high and fundamental things
everyone needs to know
they are free because we have always
wished to provide
sound learning to anyone who wishes to
have it